ich fange an bin in diesem kreuzen und
auf einmal kommen fische schafft ihr es
länger als 15 sekunden hallo mein name
ist luca und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video spielen heute das
spiel not humanity da sind wir dieses
kleine dinge in der eu was hab ich denn
jetzt gedrückt wir sind dieser kleine
punkten damit die kleine und müssen über
leben und hier das ist total schwer weil
da die ganze zeit neue sachen
reingeflogen kommen hier von der seite
es ist schwer
ich weiß nicht wie lange dieses video
wird weil auf der website steht dass man
sowas von oft stimmt und ich kann es nur
bezeugen dass man sehr oft stirbt da wo
ich das spiel gefunden
da wo ich das spiel gefunden habe stand
halt so was wenn man es über fünf
sekunden schafft soll man auf jeden fall
schon mal recht gut sein
waren das mehr als fünf sekunden gerade
meine nächste challenge ist es mehr als
15 sekunden zu schaffen das habt ihr ja
brand es ist nicht wahr
dieses spiel das geht nicht als ihr
denkt dass ich hatte nur die dummen die
party rausnehmen
waters war ging ich weiß auch gar nicht
wie ich das nachher schneiden soll das
sind ja ich muss er zehn milliarden katz
setzen einfach weil ich nicht
wahrscheinlich war ich muss ja 18.000
cup setzen weil ich nicht hinkriege hier
irgendwie oh mein gott okay hier
zwischen dass ich eigentlich recht gut
aus dass ich unglaublich gut aus und
jetzt hier aber da kommen die fische ort
da oben hier rein und da ist keine da
kriegt mich keiner und nicht an
theoretisch in diesem land schafften
auch die 15 sekunden um mein gott da
bleibt
ich habe ein neues design und kann jetzt
ein chaos wählen enorme level dekan auf
lautende space of the earth ja das ist
die story hinter dem ganzen die erde des
kaputt gegangen und wir sind im weltall
und sterben aus total oft ich sehe auch
gerade dass die challenge nicht wahr
dass man fünf sekunden überlegen soll
sondern 15 sekunden
ich weiß nicht wie ich das hinkriegen
soll ich glaube bei allen 15 sekunden
bekommt man dann nachher irgendwas mein
highscore ist warte ich töte mich mal
kurzmann highscore ist 18,97 und das
wird in sekunden berechnet
das heißt einmal habe ich schon
geschafft und desto öfter man das
schafft desto mehr von diesen boxen kann
man letztendlich dann wahrscheinlich
nach eröffnen um sich dann irgendwie
neue designs auch gut dass im weltraum
einfach so eine riesige hand auf dich
drauf klatsch kommt ich bin ganz gut mit
dabei bin gerade schon bei fünf sekunden
hier was macht diese kleinen [ __ ] hat
riesige haare es ist halt einfach
schwierig es ist nicht schwierig den
auszuweichen aber dass die teile dann
wirklich einfach in die sachen ja da
kommt in fischers hat echt blöd ich
starte das match und ich kann quasi gar
nicht richtig ausweichen ich versuche
jetzt irgendwie ich bleibe hier geguckt
jeder rein da geht nichts mehr es ist
unmöglich ich fange an bin in diesem
kreuz auf einmal kommen fische schafft
ihr es länger als 15 sekunden ich habe
es einmal 18 sekunden schafft aber
seitdem ist es einfach nur so dass ich
total am struggle bin ich aber halt
nicht mal war es eigentlich mag ich
solche spiele wo man so ein bisschen
wirklich an seine grenzen kommen diese
bald die 20 zünder aus mache ich meine
der lieder fertig waren machen wir
zwischendurch mal kurzen kartentrick
meine lieben freunde zieht irgendeine
karte nimmt hier welche sehen ob meine
karten sind runter gefallen das war das
ende des kartentricks setzen jetzt
einfach mal ein anderes ziel und versuch
am schnellsten zu sterben das war 67
sekunden war schon jetzt ok 50 sekunden
habe ich schon mal jetzt 32 sekunden
anstatt diese 15 sekunden zu schaffen
also jetzt einfach so schnell wie
möglich zu sterben dann könnt ihr mir
das mich auch besser die kommentare
schreiben ob wir das auch hinkriegen so
schnell zu sterben
also ich glaub 32 sekunden war schon
unfassbar gut ich versuche mal eben
gerade nochmal die 15 sekunden zu
schaffen weil ich daran gerade echt
interessiert bin ich bin schon mal zwölf
um ein gott freunde bekamen nur 1 24 und
die neue box ist ein stuhl damit sogar
noch das geht bis 50 sekunden hinter
deinen space ich habe ein neues symbol
und zwar eine karotte die ist
tatsächlich jetzt auch an veh ich mag
karotten eigentlich aber diese hier ist
so blöd am 10
die bringen einfach kein glück freude
dass hier der letzte hand an die karotte
es irgendwie schaffen wir noch mal ein
besseres
was soll das